[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN PETRENKO: Hey,
welcome to Google Chicago.
Right now we have some
amazing people here with us.
My name is John Petrenko,
I've been in specialty coffee
for the last nine years or so.
And again, I'm a huge
fan of Intelligentsia,
and I'm totally affecting
some nervous energy here.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
I would like to introduce
our panel right now.
To my right, we have
James McLaughlin,
he's the CEO and president
of Intelligentsia Coffee.
Followed by Sam Sabori,
the national roasting
and quality control manager.
Then Michael Sheridan
is the director
of sourcing and shared
value at Intelligentsia
Coffee in Chicago.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you for coming
out to Google Chicago.
It's a pleasure to
have you guys here.
We really want to get
into all these questions,
and just really dive into what
makes Intelligentsia amazing,
because it is super amazing.
I love it so much, I go
there as much as possible.
I mean, we just
want to know what
makes Intelligentsia
Intelligentsia,
and what makes you guys--
like where you guys came from
to be where you're at today.
So to get into it right
now, this question
is for all of you guys.
How did you guys get
your start in coffee?
And how did you become
so successful in coffee?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Want
to start, Michael?
MICHAEL SHERIDAN:
I love the premise.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: How did I
become so successful in coffee?
Well first of all,
thanks for having us.
We're big fans of Google
and it's a real pleasure
to be here.
I love this question,
and it comes up
a lot at coffee events.
And I love it because usually
people's story in coffee
begins with something like,
well I was a liberal arts major,
or I was an arts studies major.
I was a philosophy major,
which of course means
I'm not qualified to do
anything other than press
buttons on a coffee
machine at Starbucks.
So a lot of people's coffee--
everybody comes to coffee
from different places
because there isn't an Academy.
We met last week, the woman who
runs some of the food program
here, and she went to the
Culinary Institute of America.
There isn't something
like that for coffee,
so people come from all
kinds of different places.
I myself came from a
really bizarre direction,
which was international
development about 20 years ago,
as a volunteer in
Central America.
And I was placed in a coffee
village, a coffee growing
village with someone
who is obsessed
with coffee as a consumer.
And then I just pursued
it, and found a way
to work my way into
coffee through the channel
of international development.
So a lot of people
will start as baristas
and try to find their way
to where coffee is grown.
I started where coffee was grown
and found my way into places
where I work with baristas.
SAM SABORI: I'm the
arts major stereotype.
Yeah, I got into
coffee in college
as a barista, that sustained
me through college.
And then I got a job
at a specialty shop,
and I was kind of debating
further education.
So grad school, or--
I really wasn't sure.
So I decided to take a year
to have fun with coffee.
And then one year led to
two, and two led to three,
and then eventually I
got a job at Intelli,
and here I am 10 years later.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah, I just
want to echo what Michael said.
Thank you so much for having us.
We're active users of many
of your Google products,
we love them all.
And we're neighbors, because
we actually roast probably
six blocks west of here.
So it's really cool to be
here and talk to you guys
a little bit about coffee.
I'm the philosophy
major of the group.
But I took a somewhat
unusual route to coffee.
I ended up practicing
law here in Chicago
for a number of years.
I was a regular
at Intelligentsia
in Millennium Park.
And in 2009, I quit my
job, moved with my wife
down to Brazil, and
managed a coffee farm.
So I ran a coffee farm for three
years and got the coffee bug,
and really decided that that was
something I wanted to stay in.
We ended up moving back
to the United States.
And I was a huge fan
of Intelligentsia,
just a true believer in
what the company stood
for, all the things that
they were focused on,
particularly the origin.
And I sent a cold letter
to the company and said,
hey, here's who I am, I'd
love to come work for you.
And one thing led to
another, and here we are.
JOHN PETRENKO: Very
cool, very cool.
Now about Intelligentsia,
I'm curious like,
what is the inspiration
behind Intelligentsia?
What does it mean,
like, what does
it mean to specialty coffee?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
It's a great question.
I think to answer it,
I want to go back.
I mean, coffee is one of the
world's most widely traded
commodities.
And when Intelligentsia
was founded 23 years ago,
this idea of specialty
coffee really didn't exist.
I mean, there were people
that we're trying to do--
well, I shouldn't say that.
I mean, Peet's
and Starbucks were
sort of the second
wave, what's commonly
called the second wave
of coffee, the upgrade
from Folgers.
And when Intelligentsia
was founded 23 years ago,
it was this idea
that, hey, coffee
can actually be something more.
We really need to treat
coffee as a culinary product,
much more so than Starbucks
and Peet's were doing.
And it became--
I think what
Intelligentsia has always
stood for is this
idea that we want
to keep the pristine ingredient
that comes from the farm as
pure and as intact--
and present that
to our customers--
as possible.
And that really gives
us an opportunity
to showcase all the different
varietals and origins,
and all the different taste
characteristics that I know
you're super familiar with.
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: And you know,
one of the things that we truly
believe is that we
have the opportunity
to make change in the world
through extraordinary coffee.
I mean, when we talk about
coffee at Intelligentsia,
it is always
extraordinary coffee,
because we are buying,
roasting, and serving
the best coffee in the world.
And we believe that really
through our trading model,
the way that we buy
and sell coffees,
we can have a huge impact on
the communities in countries
all across the world and
give farmers an opportunity
to make a living and a
livelihood that is totally
disconnected from
that commodity market
that I talked about
at the beginning.
So I think, you know, it's
really about treating coffee
as a culinary product that
carries through in, I think,
everything that we do.
JOHN PETRENKO: Definitely.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN:
At our coffee bars,
we were really at the
forefront of introducing
high design into coffee bars.
If you go to our coffee
bars, everyone is different.
We try to design coffee bars
for the specific neighborhood,
and make it feel
like that customer--
that's their coffee bar,
that's their Intelligentsia.
It's not a cookie cutter model.
And so all these
little details--
you know, I like to say that
if a customer knows nothing
about Intelligentsia and you
walk into one of our shops,
hopefully that customer stops
as soon as they cross the door
threshold and they say,
wait, something's different,
this doesn't feel like
a common coffee shop.
And that's something that
we want to have happen,
because we want to elevate the
coffee experience to something
culinary.
And it really carries through
to all the small details.
We don't have any cups, but the
cups that we use in our shops,
that was stuff that we
designed because we didn't like
the way the cups felt in
our hands, the ones that
were commonly on the market.
So we designed one where you
had a place to rest your thumb.
We designed the inside
so that you could easily
pour latte art.
And again, the presentation was
something that was different.
Another, I think, good
example is the menu
that we print every
day at our shop.
We get to pick the
coffees we serve,
and it's something different
each and every day.
And it's this idea that, hey,
coffee is not just coffee.
There's coffee
from Peru, there's
coffee from El Salvador,
there's coffee from Rwanda.
And then there's
50 different levels
below that, that we're
just really starting
to scratch the surface.
JOHN PETRENKO: Totally.
I mean, and that leads
to my next question.
And this is just like, a
coffee fanboy question.
What is your favorite coffee?
What is your favorite process,
region, and brewing technique?
You know, I love making
a Kalita Wave at home,
Costa Rica is my favorite.
I love a pulp natural.
[LAUGHTER]
All three of you guys,
I'd really like to know.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
SAM SABORI: I honestly think
you can make great coffee
on any device, it's
just, how much time do
you want to spend with it?
Some are easier than others.
I personally, I
kind of fluctuate
between a Chemex
or a Kalita Wave.
I tend to prefer smaller
doses, so I'll usually
dose around 22, 23 grams
and run a 1 to 18.25
ratio if you guys
are interested.
JOHN PETRENKO: There you go.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM SABORI: And as far
as favorite coffee,
I would say Kenya is
probably my favorite.
It just has so much power.
There's tons of sweetness,
tons of acidity,
and there's just
so much to develop
from a roast perspective
and a brewing perspective.
JOHN PETRENKO: Definitely.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: I don't
want to go after that.
[LAUGHTER]
18.25 to 1.
I have a little less
precision in my own habits.
I'll say that in our office,
the culture is to share too.
We have a nice
brew bar, and we've
got every different kind
of manual brewing method
available.
So the Chemex tends to
be my method of choice,
and I bring it back and share it
with my neighbors where I sit.
It's a little bit unforgiving
sometimes, hard to dial in.
I've done a lot more work
with the Kalita lately.
But I just can't--
anytime there's a fresh crop
Ethiopia on the coffee bar,
I can't pass it up.
And we've got a couple that
we're brewing up for you here
today, including one that is
just incredibly floral and just
endlessly sweet.
And for a lot of
people, Ethiopia's
a challenging coffee because
it doesn't taste like coffee.
It's very complex and
it's got a lot going on.
And for some people, it's
not an everyday coffee.
But if I could have
one coffee on a desert
island for the rest of my
life, it would be the Ethiopia.
JOHN PETRENKO: Perfect.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
I'd second that.
I think a washed Ethiopian
is probably my favorite.
And I personally prefer the
Chemex, but I agree with Sam,
you can make great
coffee on anything.
But if I had to choose
one, it would be Chemex.
JOHN PETRENKO: Chemex,
yeah, makes sense.
Yeah.
So this is for Michael.
I was just wondering,
can you tell us
about Intelligentsia's
model on sourcing coffee?
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah.
I thought you'd never ask.
JOHN PETRENKO: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SHERIDAN:
I mentioned before
that I got into coffee through
international development.
And what I neglected to say,
was that I spent 14 years
with an international
aid agency,
and I spent 12 of those
years working on coffee.
And it was kind of
an interesting thing
because I was living in
Guatemala for four years,
and in South America
for five years,
and I was leading projects with
thousands of smallholder coffee
growers.
One of the things that's
amazing about coffee
from an impact perspective
or a development perspective,
is that it's a
poor person's crop.
It's primarily grown
by smallholder farmers
who have maybe three,
or four, or five acres.
So there's incredible
developmental potential
in coffee in general, and
specifically in our model.
But that's why a development
agency was so deeply
invested in coffee.
But one of the nice
things about that work
was, it was kind of
like Switzerland.
We were totally neutral.
And everybody in
the coffee industry
is like, oh you're working on
coffee to make coffee better,
more impactful for
smallholders, how can we help?
And so people would
fling open their doors.
And I had over those 12
years, the opportunity
to work with roasters
of all shapes and sizes.
And I think that
Intelligentsia's sourcing
program is awesome, but it's not
because I work for the company.
I work for the company
because I think the sourcing
program is awesome.
As I did more and
more of that work
and I decided to make a
move to the private sector,
there were really
very few companies
that from a developmental
perspective were interesting.
And Intelligentsia was really
at the top of the list.
So we did get the questions
for this in advance,
so I did get to
glance at it, and I
made a long list of things
that make our sourcing program
awesome.
I'm going to try to limit
myself to like four or five here
and just hit them quickly.
But I could go down
to like 17 or 18 later
if you're interested
after we break.
The first thing I'll
say about our program
is, our program is
called Direct Trade.
And it's language,
or it's a term that's
used a lot in the industry
now, but really Intelligentsia
developed the concept.
One of our colleagues,
Geoff Watts,
was sort of the primary
intellectual and material
author of the model.
And the most important
part about that
is, the direct part
of Direct Trade.
And it's just what
it sounds like.
We visit every one of our direct
trade partners every year,
on their farms, in their
mills, and we work together
to build the beautiful coffees
that we serve in our coffee
bars and that you'll try today.
And from a sourcing
perspective, I
believe it's the most reliable
way to get great coffee.
From a developmental
perspective,
there's simply no
substitute for a situation
in which a buyer is sitting
across the table from a grower
and talking about what
they're going to do together,
how we're going to create
quality, what kind of volumes
we're going to work on
together this year, what
are the specific
economic practices
or post harvest practices
that can lead to quality.
And there's just something
magical about that face
to face contact.
There are a lot of
certification programs
out there, fair trade,
bird friendly, shade grown.
They're all good.
But for a lot of
people, that is a way
to outsource relationships.
People do that
because they don't
visit the farms every year.
It's really fundamental
to our model,
and it's the way that
we build quality.
So the direct in direct
trade is important.
The second thing
I'll say is, that's
really important about
the program, is quality.
We believe that-- as James
said, he mentioned the word
culinary five or six times.
It's such a bedrock
belief of ours,
that coffee is a
culinary product.
And it is a commodity, but
not the coffee that we source,
not the coffee that we
serve, and not the way
we think about coffee.
We think about coffee
as something elevated.
It's a gastronomic
product, and the way
we serve it is an
elevated process.
And we build our partnerships
with that in mind.
We find people who share
our obsession with quality,
and we build relationships
with them that last.
For us, we think it's the most
important and effective way
to be successful
in the marketplace.
And it turns out, the same
thing is true for growers.
The most reliable value
proposition for growers
is to produce quality
year after year.
The third thing is, the
way we trade coffee,
or our commercial contracts.
And in order to
understand what's
special about the
way we do it, you
need to understand a
little bit about the way
the market normally works.
And the market the
market normally works
is, it's really intermediated.
Coffee growers rarely
taste their own coffee.
They almost never
meet coffee buyers.
They'll sell their
coffee to someone
in the town plaza,
who will maybe
resell it to a miller,
who will then export it.
And the two ends of
the chain don't meet.
We build this model
directly with growers.
And we build
incentives for quality.
It's not just that we pay
more, we pay high prices,
we pay stable prices.
Normally the prices that growers
get, the market graph in coffee
looks a little bit
like a seismograph
or a polygraph test.
It looks like this, and
it's very hard for a grower
to make a living with
prices that go up and down.
We pay stable, high fixed
prices so that growers
know what they're going
to make from us this year,
what they're going to make
next year, what they going
to make the year after that.
And the growers in
our supply chain
have something that is a rare
and beautiful thing, which
is the ability to make
plans for the future.
And most growers are
not in that position.
So I'm going to
stop there at three.
I could go on, but there is one
more that I want to mention.
It's called ECW.
One of the amazing things for us
is that we work with some of--
James said, we source and serve
the best coffees in the world.
And we work with some of
the most celebrated coffee
growers in the world.
In 10 countries
around the world,
there's a coffee
competition every year
called the Cup of Excellence.
And growers from
all over the country
will submit samples
of their coffee.
There is a national jury
that will go through it three
or four times, and
they'll identify
a small number of lots that
qualify for the final jury.
And then international cuppers
come from all over the world,
they sample the coffees,
they grade them,
and then they're
sold at auction.
We have like, a dozen different
Cup of Excellence winners
in our supply network.
And we once a year get everybody
in our supply chain network
together for an event we
call the Extraordinary Coffee
Workshop.
We just did our 10th annual
one last month in Bolivia.
And when you get there,
it's like the all-star game
of coffee.
It's like, people are
looking around the room
and they're going, oh yeah, it's
you, I know about your coffee
and you won Cup of
Excellence in Honduras,
Excellence in Rwanda.
And we've been doing
this now for 10 years.
A lot of these people
are people we've
traded with for 12 or 15 years.
And they haven't just
become friends with us,
but they've become
friends with one another.
And so it's like, it's sort
of a part family reunion, part
coffee geek week,
where we geek out
on all the details of coffee
agronomy and processing,
and try to find little
things that we can unlock
to make our coffee better.
And that level of transparency,
and that level of exchange
where the best in the world
are learning from the best,
and we're facilitating it, it's
something that just doesn't
happen anywhere else in coffee.
So that's one of the
most extraordinary things
that Intelligentsia does.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: And if
I could just add, I mean,
from the perspective
of a grower--
because I was a grower
for a number of years--
what Michael just described
probably doesn't sound that--
like, it all make sense, right?
You have a buyer sitting
across from a seller,
they were paying prices based on
quality, that all kind of makes
sense intuitively.
But the point that
I want to emphasize,
is that that 15 years
ago did not exist.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Everything--
as Michael said-- was traded--
all coffee was really traded
through intermediaries.
And so producers
really had no idea
where their coffee
would end up going.
And you had all
these intermediaries
throughout the process that
were stepping on the product
and making a little
bit of money.
And really, the brilliance
of the Direct Trade model
that Jeff really
thought about was,
we're going to cut all those
people out and push that value
back to the producer.
And that really changes
the game as a farmer,
because you do have a partner
that you know is coming back
each and every year.
And you can make smart
business decisions,
you can start thinking
about it as a business.
I'm going to save
up my money and I'm
going to build a new wet mill.
Or I'm going to plant more land.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: And
when you're really
at the whim of the
commodity market
and you don't know
if the price is
going to be high
or low next year,
you can't really run a business.
You're really just trying to
scrape by and make a living.
And I think-- you know, I know
that you know this really well.
But it's one of
the best parts, I
think, about working in
coffee, because you really
do see the impact that our model
is having in these communities
with these farmers.
And you know, we carry that
through to the end consumer.
We expect consumers to sort of
share in paying higher prices,
because we're paying higher
prices to the producers.
But so far, consumers seem to be
willing to sort of step with us
in this.
So I think it's--
some of this stuff
sounds really intuitive,
but it's such a radical
departure for where
coffee was 15 years ago.
JOHN PETRENKO: Definitely.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: And
I think it's important,
it wasn't just 15 years ago.
I mean, most of coffee is
still traded that way today.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: That's true.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: And so
the developmental work
that I was doing in the field in
southern Colombia, for example,
with people who were coffee
growers for 30 years,
and every year they'd
go and they'd harvest,
they'd put the coffee on a
mule, and they'd take it down
to the town plaza, and they'd
sell it for whatever price
was written on the slate there.
And nothing had changed, it had
been like that for generations.
And then in that
context, I would
come in and I would bring--
when I was working for
the development agency,
I brought
Intelligentsia with me.
Just said, hey,
explain your model.
Well, here's what
we would do, here's
what we look for, here's how we
work, here's the prices we pay,
here's the quality
requirements we have.
It's not easy, you have to be
committed to quality with us.
Is anybody interested in that?
Everyone looked at
each other like,
is that a trick
question, of course we're
interested in that.
It's fundamentally revolutionary
in terms of that context.
The other thing
that James mentioned
is the idea of cutting
out the intermediaries.
We still do, in some cases,
rely on intermediaries
to do things like transport
the coffee for us.
But the key point
is, that dialogue
and getting back to
where it started,
the idea of the direct
part of direct trade.
If you think about a
traditional commodity chain,
there may be six or
eight different actors
between the coffee
bar and the grower.
And the traditional model
is that those actors
in the middle of the chain
make money off of the growers.
We're trying to make money
together with the growers,
and to be competitive
as a chain.
But even in other chains where
there's a collaborative spirit,
where there isn't
that direct contact,
it's like a game of telephone.
And you are all
educated people, you
work for Google, you
share a world view.
You share some aspects
of understanding
how the world works.
If we played a game of
telephone in here, our message,
even a simple message
would break down.
And if you think about
a supply chain that
reaches across multiple
countries, multiple languages,
different classes, it's very
hard to convey clear messages.
And so us closing
the circle, and being
able to sit down with the
grower and communicate directly,
it's like for the grower,
it's like going into an exam
with the answers ahead of time.
They know exactly what the
market is demanding of them.
There's no distortion of the
market's signal, it's direct,
it's clear, and people can make
decisions and take decisions
on the farm.
They have much higher
probability of success.
And that's the idea of
building quality together
that's so revolutionary
about Intelligentsia.
There are a lot of people
who serve quality coffee,
but they're taking what
emerges from a process
that they have no control
or influence over,
whereas we're building
the coffees every year
from the ground up,
beginning when the coffee is
a seed and still on the plant.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: And
one last point, I--
JOHN PETRENKO: Of course.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN:
But just to build
on something Michael
said, I think
that the other piece
that's really important
is the quality piece.
Because it's easy for us to talk
and say, we can go to producers
and say, here's our
quality expectations.
But it's actually pretty hard to
meet our quality expectations.
I think-- Sam can say
this better than--
I don't know the stats as well.
But I think we got
something like 3,000 samples
that we received into our
lab to evaluate and decide
whether we're going
to buy or not.
We select like 1% of
those to actually buy.
So it's not easy to
make the cut, which
is I think, your point
about the all-star team.
But we're committed
partners with the producers.
And so it often takes us
four to five years working
with a producer and saying,
look, we believe in you,
you have the right
characteristics that we found
for you to be
successful, we're going
to help train you on how
you produce quality coffee.
And often it takes
four or five years
before we'll actually
get a container of coffee
that we buy.
But it's something that,
again, this idea that we're
partners with the producers.
And the quality
road is not easy.
JOHN PETRENKO: Right on, nice.
Well, next question I have
is going to be for Sam.
I'm very curious on like, what
do you look for in the roasting
process?
What's your philosophy
in roasting and quality
control with Intelligentsia?
And follow up, what is your
favorite coffee to roast?
SAM SABORI: OK.
You know, we've echoed it a
few times, but the sentiment
that it's actually--
you approach it as if it's
any other piece of food.
You want to stabilize all your
variables first and foremost,
and that's where this Direct
Trade model comes through.
And I'm sure we'll
talk about it more,
but just having that streamlined
communication between ourselves
and the farmer to
actually understand
what's going on in the
growing conditions,
going on on the farm.
I think that's key in
playing a fundamental role
in a great roast.
As far as the
actual roast, for us
it goes anywhere from
10 to 15 minutes.
We're stabilizing variables
as often as possible.
There are some roasters,
some have a philosophy
that you want to smell the
coffee as you're roasting it,
you want to take
visual observations.
For us, we found
that the roast goes
so fast, it's really hard to
actually consistently say,
that's the color, whatever we
want from an actual numbers
perspective.
Because the way we
will roast, is we'll
roast our coffees to a
specific number on the Maillard
reaction.
So depending on
how brown it is, we
are going to roast that
to say, 55 or a 60.
And we have specific parameters
for each coffee that we want.
As far as the overall big
picture view for roasting,
we want a lot of
momentum on our coffees.
We want to roast
them efficiently,
and we want to roast them clean.
If we run them too
slow, it's kind
of like putting
an egg on a frying
pan that hasn't
been preheated, it
just kind of becomes kind of--
you don't get that
sizzle, you know?
It just kind of sits there, it's
flabby, you know you messed up.
So for us, we want to make
sure with that momentum,
we can push our coffees
as quickly as possible
with continual
reduction and heat.
I don't know if that's--
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Your
favorite to roast.
SAM SABORI: That's about as
distilled as I can make it.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PETRENKO: All
right, definitely.
And then favorite to roast?
SAM SABORI: Favorite to roast?
It'd probably be Kenya.
That's probably why it's--
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah?
Like a peaberry
or just kind of--
SAM SABORI: Probably the AAs.
So a Kenyan coffee,
they're classified
based on their screen
size, so based on how big
or small each bean is.
And each grade as it goes
from AB to AA, AB or AA,
or lower grades, they just
continue to get refined.
So the AA, say that's one of
the better milling constructions
that we can get, that
allows us to be a lot more
direct with our approach.
And it allows us to kind of
push the coffees further.
Whereas if say we were
roasting a coffee that's
borderline specialty,
say not from Kenya,
we might have to adjust
our roast approach
to slow down or speed up.
Because if we roast
it at any other level,
we're going to
get vegetal notes,
we're going to get sour notes,
we're going to get astringency.
So a lot of times when you're
tasting a coffee that's
borderline specialty,
the roaster
is making a decision to take it
that far because he's actually
trying to minimize
the negatives.
Whereas with a
Kenyan coffee, you
can kind of keep
pushing them to continue
to expand the complexity.
JOHN PETRENKO: OK.
Very cool.
Another question is, since you
guys are founded in Chicago
and we are in Google
Chicago, you guys
operate in many
different cities.
I'm wondering how you keep your
Chicago identity while you keep
expanding into other markets?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
You know, when we
go into new markets,
we really try to become
part of the community.
And LA was the first city
where we expanded into.
And I think-- you know,
I've heard anecdotally
that there's a lot
of people that think
Intelligentsia is an LA brand.
And that's really part of what
we want to do in each new city
we go into.
And I think there's
things, there's
core things that
we try to keep true
across all of our coffee bars.
I mean, quality is obviously
the most important.
Making sure that
the coffee always
tastes the way we want
it to is fundamental.
And it's probably
the hardest thing
as we expand into new
cities, making sure
that we have the team and
the people that can maintain
our quality standards.
But from a brand
perspective, it's
very much, we want to become
part of the neighborhoods,
we want to become part
of the communities.
I think it's probably no
different than Google,
you know, Google Chicago.
And so we try to
find different ways
to engage with the communities
when we go into new cities,
and really become part of the
fabric of the neighborhood.
JOHN PETRENKO: All
right, very cool.
What's your favorite
Chicago Intelligentsia?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Definitely
the Monadnock location.
JOHN PETRENKO: Oh, OK.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Just the
old school, it's in the--
that building was at one point
the world's tallest building.
It's a completely
brick structure.
So it's not very tall.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think that's a great
example of some of the design
choices we make.
You know, if you go into there,
it's all marble countertops,
there's a brass bar, it
feels old, modern but old.
And it's sort of supposed
to reflect that building
and that architecture.
So that would be
my favorite one.
JOHN PETRENKO: All right.
Anybody else?
SAM SABORI: Favorite cafe?
I'd probably say Wicker because
it's closest to my house.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PETRENKO: That's a fun one.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah,
Wicker's on my route in.
JOHN PETRENKO: Wicker?
All right, very cool.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: It's the
off-site conference room.
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah,
no, that's a fun one.
I love that one.
So one thing is like, with
climate change affecting
crop production and farming
all across the world,
how do you see coffee being
affected by this crisis?
And how do you see
coffee going forward
if these trends aren't reversed?
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah.
So climate change is a big deal
in every aspect of our lives,
and coffee is no exception.
Climate change is--
I've heard coffee described,
I think accurately,
as a Goldilocks crop.
Can't be too hot,
it can be too cold.
It has to be just right.
It can't have too much rain,
it can have too little rain.
It has to have just the
right amount of rain.
Arabica coffee, which
is what we source,
the specialty coffee is
almost entirely Arabica.
It's a very finicky crop.
And it grows in the tropics
at a certain elevation range,
and has these requirements
for temperature and rain.
And those are getting
changed with climate change.
And I think there's been
a lot of research on this,
and general tendency
that people see in coffee
is that the optimal elevation
for coffee, the elevation
range for coffee is rising
as temperatures rise.
So coffee likes the cool.
One of the things we look
at when we source coffee
is the diurnal temperature
range, so the difference
between the high in the
midday and the low at night.
And the cool temperatures
stress the plant,
and they contribute
to the creation
of these beautiful
complex flavors.
And that cool, to get
that kind of cool,
you have to go
higher and higher.
And we know because of
the nature of mountains,
the higher you go, the
less land is available.
So coffee lands are going away
under a kind of a business
as usual scenario.
And there's very little
that a grower can do.
Growers can mitigate the effects
of that and sort of forestall
that through their management
practices by managing shade
more intensively, lowering
the ambient temperature
of their coffee groves.
But ultimately,
they're not going
to be able to make
the kinds of changes
on the farm to keep up
with climate change.
So one of the very
important short term things
is working with
growers to implement
some of those things that
will help to optimize
the quality of their coffee.
But the long term, we
require more research.
So all the staple
crops that we consume,
rice, and corn,
and wheat, they all
have publicly funded
research institutes.
But coffee as a
cash crop does not.
And so the industry has
been working together
over the last 5 to
10 years to create
a collective research--
an industry driven
research agency.
They're looking for sort
of the holy grail, which
is a combination of varieties
that resist drought and disease
and they produce a
beautiful flavor in the cup.
Generally plant breeders are
just focused on productivity,
they want to maximize yield and
they don't think about flavor.
There's an
organization that we've
been supporting
since its inception,
since it was just in
the concept phase,
it's called World
Coffee Research.
And this is their
pursuit, to make
specialty coffee viable in
an era of accelerated climate
change.
And they're doing-- they've done
more in the last 5 to 10 years
on plant breeding
through partnerships
with the local
research institutes
throughout the
coffee growing world
than has been done in
the history of specialty
leading up to it.
And we contribute, we consider
it part of our cost of goods.
We contribute a half a penny per
pound for every pound of coffee
that we buy to
this research fund.
James sits on the board as
another part of our belief in
and commitment to this effort.
And it's fundamental.
But it's definitely
changing things,
and it is changing the
patterns of disease,
changing cup profile.
And it's changing so fast that--
we're so deeply engaged
with our partners
on the coffees that
come in every year,
and we're cupping them
throughout their life span.
And so we're working
to give feedback
and trying to see what the
changes are in the cup.
We're continuing to
source amazing coffees,
but it's something
that everybody
in every aspect, every step in
the supply chain is working on.
So we're funding research,
we're working at the farm level
to deal with it.
We're trying to promote
water saving technologies.
But it's a challenge
in coffee as it
is in all of agriculture and
every human endeavor really.
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
I mean, just two
specific examples.
Where I was living in
Brazil, that region just
came out of the worst drought.
They were in a two year drought.
And many, many producers
in the region where I was
have abandoned their farms,
because the coffee trees died.
And given that most
of these producers
aren't focused on
quality, there's
really no future for them.
So given that it is
mostly a smallholder crop,
it's a huge risk to the
industry as a whole.
The other example was,
as Michael mentioned,
the other problem with
climate change is disease.
Five years ago, four years
ago, Central America--
all the countries
in Central America--
had an outbreak of a disease
called leaf rust, and really
devastated Guatemala,
Honduras, El Salvador,
and wiped out many, many farms.
And it's really a product
of higher temperatures
allows this fungus to
breed more rapidly.
And as Michael mentioned,
the future really
is in plant breeding
and figuring out
how to create the
super plant that
can produce higher quality,
resist disease, resist higher
temperatures.
But frankly, as an industry,
we're pretty far behind
in terms of that research.
And we're-- there's a lot of
pressure to catch up quickly.
JOHN PETRENKO: I
think we don't need
argue that technology
and the internet
has been pretty disruptive
in the past two decades.
How has it changed
for your business?
That and like, social
media and everything.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN:
So I'm going to take
this in a couple
different directions.
JOHN PETRENKO: Great.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: The first
I think is, in some ways,
I think coffee
hasn't changed much.
I mean, if you look at the
roasters that we use today,
they're the same roasters that
we've used 80, 90 years ago.
There's some upgrades
here and there.
But overall, it's like you
apply heat to this metal drum,
you put green coffee
in, and it turns brown.
So in some ways, I
think there's frankly
a huge opportunity
for the industry
to kind of catch
up and figure out,
are there other ways
to make coffee--
to turn coffee brown?
So that's point number one.
There's pretty cool stuff
that's happening though,
in terms of the
ability to produce
great tasting cups of coffee
where it doesn't require
a lot of manual work.
I mean, one of the things
that we always talk about
is, when you think about all
the different people that touch
coffee in the supply chain;
from the producer, their choices
in the varietal;
the picker, they
choose which cherries they're
going to put in the bill--
in the bag; the
miller, the wet mill,
the dry mill; the roaster;
the barista; the end user.
I mean, there's so
many people that
can affect how a cup
of coffee tastes.
And we really--
I think where we are going
to go as an industry, where
this industry is
going is, that's
going to get whittled down.
Frankly we have too many people
that can affect the flavor
and not really optimize it.
And I think what we're going
to see over the next 5 or 10
years is, the number
of people that--
we're going to get coffee
into consumers' hands
in a finished good
kind of way that
actually tastes
amazing in a better way
than we do currently.
Selling a consumer
a bag of coffee
is always terrifying for us.
Because they take it home,
they put it in their grinder,
they add too much water, they
don't do 18.25 to 1 ratio.
And then they look at the
bag and they say, gosh,
why does Intelligentsia
coffee not taste great?
And it's like,
no, but you didn't
do all these different things.
So I think there's-- from
a technology standpoint,
I think there's
more from a brewing,
roasting perspective that
is starting to happen,
but hasn't really happened--
hasn't caught up yet.
I was in Brazil--
I still buy coffee for
Brazil for Intelligentsia--
and I was on this farm, and
they actually grow grapes there.
And they have a-- they're
starting a winery.
And so we took a day's
picking of coffee
and we took it to the winery and
we used the winery's equipment
to process the coffee.
Like super precise,
super detailed.
We had this trained
professional, wine professional
there consulting with us.
And you don't see
that in coffee today,
it's still pretty random
and haphazard on the farm.
So I think there's
a lot of opportunity
in terms of being more precise
throughout the whole supply
chain.
I think to get to
your second question,
the great thing about social
media and the internet
is that it's given
voices to smaller brands
like Intelligentsia,
where we can actually
reach more people in a way that
we couldn't have 20 years ago.
And education is one of
the most important things
for a company like us.
Why do you pay $22 for
a bag of Tikur Anbessa
from Ethiopia when
there's a bag of Starbucks
at the grocery store for $7?
So what is different
about Intelligentsia
from Starbucks, it's both
brown beans in a bag?
And it really gives us a
chance to educate consumers
about all the things we've
been talking about today.
That, and then also
educate consumers
about how to brew the cup
of coffee so it tastes good.
JOHN PETRENKO:
Definitely, definitely.
One kind of fanboy
question I have is,
you guys go out to origin.
It's something I've always
really dreamed of doing,
I think it would be amazing.
I'm curious, what are your
favorite trips of origin
to go to, and maybe like
a fun crazy story that
has happened while at origin?
That's for all three of you.
SAM SABORI: I think
you've got this one.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: I think I know
the story you want me to tell.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not always fun stuff
that happens at origin.
Sometimes crazy stuff happens
that's not entirely fun.
Well I think it's--
certainly it's like, there's
kind of this thing in coffee,
and not everybody falls
into the same pattern.
But the principle entry point
for coffee is as a barista.
Like you just heard Sam's
experience, it's pretty common.
People when they--
they're a barista,
and if it's just that they want
benefits and pay for school
and they're out, there out.
But a lot of people
catch the bug
and they get totally passionate
about this thing that's
endlessly complex and
really fascinating, way
more interesting than they ever
thought it was when they were
just trying to pay some bills.
And they go down
the rabbit hole.
And generally, the
more people get
interested in coffee, the more
they get interested in where
it comes from, and the
people who grow it,
and they want to get to origin.
And so there's something kind
of mythical about getting
to take your first origin trip.
It's sort of like a milestone
in the professional development
of serious coffee people.
And so there's no question,
it's the highlight of the job.
All three of us here
buy coffee in addition
to the work we do
at the roasting
works a couple of
blocks from here.
So the trips are things
we look forward to.
And we take at least one a
year, sometimes more than one
when we have a special
project going on.
And we look forward to it.
And it's a time when
you cut through all
the emails and the phone calls,
and you just sit on the farm.
And there just something magical
about being on a coffee farm.
I particularly love
shade grown coffee,
where you're outside
in the tropical sun
and it's hot, maybe 70 degrees,
but a really strong sun.
And you step into
the coffee grove
and the temperature drops like
12 degrees, and it's cool,
and you feel the moisture,
and you understand what
the shade does for the coffee.
And then you're doing it
together with a grower,
and it's great.
And there's a lot of
planning that goes into it.
You talk about, hey,
here's what we'd
like to do together this year.
Last year we bought this much,
we'd like to buy a little more,
we'd like to buy a
little less, we'd
like it to be more like
this, or less like that.
So you do all this
planning and then you go
and you're on the farm
together, you're at the mill
together putting
in place the plan.
What they want me
to talk about is,
last year we did
all this planning.
[LAUGHTER]
I made my first trip as the
new coffee buyer in Bolivia.
We have this really
exciting farm there.
We're going to have
coffee from this farm
in just a couple of weeks.
It's called Finca
Takesi and it lays
the claim to being the highest
coffee farm in the world.
And we've been buying coffee,
we bought coffee in 20 countries
over the last 23
years and we've never
found a higher coffee farm.
So we have no evidence to
suggest the claim is untrue.
So for me, I was going
to the highest coffee
farm in the world, I
was really excited,
my first trip to Bolivia.
Bolivia's kind of a bit
of a backwater country
as far as anything goes.
It's landlocked, it's
very hard to get to,
all the flights
arrive at 3:00 AM.
I wanted to save the
company a couple of nickels,
and I had a complicated
itinerary that
had two stops instead of one.
And I went to the first
stop on the first day
and I missed my connection,
I had to wait a day,
so I spent a night in Guatemala.
And then I went the
next day to Colombia
and I missed my
connection there,
so I had to spend a
night in Colombia.
So on the third day
after leaving Chicago,
I pull in at 3:00 AM
to La Paz in Bolivia.
And my partner picks us up
and we head out to the field,
and we're about 10
minutes from the farm,
and in the Bolivian Andes,
these commanding Bolivian Andes.
And the car flipped and
rolled over once, twice,
three, five or six times.
And we dropped about
100 meters down the side
of one of these big mountains.
And by some sort of miracle,
we both emerged unscathed.
But I had had enough.
I was mentally a
little bit taxed,
so I got on the
next flight home.
So I spent five days
on a sourcing trip,
and I spent about 13
minutes on a farm,
and then I was evacuated to
go to a hospital [INAUDIBLE]..
All that hard
planning, it doesn't--
careful planning doesn't
always lead to success.
But I was just there
last month, no incidents.
The coffee is beautiful
and delicious.
One of the things we
do at our ECW event,
is the last two years we've
had a coffee competition, which
is just awesome.
So think about the all-star team
of coffee, everybody bringing
the best two kilos of coffee
they can produce to the table.
Sam roasts it, we all
cup it, we qualify it,
and then the growers
themselves vote.
We have awards that are voted
on by everybody in the supply
chain.
So they're tasting
each other's coffees,
they're looking around the
room, they're all blindly coded.
So people are going, is
this mine, is that hers,
is it his, whose is it?
And then we reveal the coffees.
So this coffee from this farm
was voted the best coffee
in the southern hemisphere,
best coffee in South America,
and we've got two bags of this
coffee that are coming in,
two 60 kilo bags that are coming
in in a couple of weeks' time.
So we'll make a
big deal about it
when it arrives, and it's
going to be delicious.
So in the end, it will
all have been worth it.
JOHN PETRENKO: Very cool.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I think we
are about time for--
to open up to a
Q&A. So if anybody
wants to ask a
question, we'll have
a microphone running around.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned the three waves.
What do you think is wave
number four if it comes?
And what's the future of
both coffee production,
to your earlier question,
and coffee consumption?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Well I'll
start and you guys can jump in.
I think we're going
to continue to see--
on the production side--
I think we're going to continue
to see a segregation of farms.
On the commodity side,
what you're seeing across
the world is this move to
massive, massive farms,
primarily in Brazil
and Vietnam where
all of the work on the farm
is being done mechanically.
And so that, I think,
will continue to grow.
Those farms are
becoming so efficient
that they can make
money even when
the commodity market is at $1.
Most farms-- I don't
know if you have a stat,
for some reason I want--
I think it's like--
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: $1.40, $1.50.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah. $1.40,
$1.50 is kind of break even
for most farmers.
And so I think you're
going to continue
to see that agribusiness
grow for the commodity side.
On the specialty side--
and so that model is
not sustainable for most
smallholders.
The smallholder is
never going to compete
with the massive
farm in Brazil that
has huge tractors,
and everything else,
and all this money behind it.
So the only hope, in my
opinion, for the smallholder
is to focus on quality and
go the route of specialty.
That requires an investment,
it requires time, it's
not something that you
just turn on overnight.
But I don't think there's
going to be a middle ground.
Either you're doing
specialty coffee,
or you're in the
commodity world.
I just don't see a future
for the smallholder trying
to produce commodity coffee.
I kind of alluded to
this earlier, I believe--
there's so much more
complexity in coffee
than we currently understand.
There's varietals,
there's processing method,
there's the stuff that
Sam does with the roaster.
And the average consumer
still doesn't get it.
There's so much more for us
to unlock for the consumer.
And it's something that
we talk a lot about, is
how do we communicate
the complexity of coffee,
and how do we do
it in a way that
doesn't overwhelm the consumer?
And I don't know that we've
totally figured it out.
We're trying, but I think
over the next 5 to 10 years,
coffee is going to continue
to go the route of wine,
where consumers
start to say, wow, I
really like the Catuai variety
processed in a washed method,
or a pulp natural method,
and I really like Costa Rica.
One of the things-- one
of the concepts that we've
introduced at Intelligentsia
is this idea of seasonality.
And so if you go into
one of our coffee bars,
you'll see a sticker that says,
some bags say it's in season.
And the reason we do that is
because what we have found
is that one of the most
important factors to freshness
and taste is the number
of days off of harvest.
Everyone always
talks about roast,
and roast date is
really important.
Eh, it is, but I
think we're missing
a huge part of it,
which is how old is it,
how many days off of
the harvest is it?
And so there's really two
buying seasons in the world.
There's coffee from the
northern hemisphere,
it all harvests at more
or less the same time.
And countries in the southern
hemisphere, more or less
harvest at the same time.
And so we use as a rule, nine
months off of harvest, that's
considered in season for us.
And that's really
where you're going
to get the peak of
flavors and freshness.
And I use that as an example.
I mean, that's just--
again, we're just scratching
the surface with this stuff.
There's so much more
complexity-- as you know--
to coffee.
And we as an industry,
I think, have
to continue to push
consumers to understand,
hey, there's all these different
variables that affect flavor,
and we need to educate consumers
around what coffees they like,
and then take them on a journey
in their coffee life, you know?
If you really like the pulp
natural from Brazil, that's
great, we're going to kind
of introduce you there,
then we might take
you to Peru, then we
might take you to
Honduras, and then we
might take you to East Africa.
There's really, I think, an
evolution in most consumers
coffee journeys, their lives.
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Yeah, I mean,
I see both of those things.
I think at origin, there's going
to be a consolidation where
we have fewer and fewer growers
of small-- fewer and fewer
smallholder growers.
And I think that we're going
to get this really bifurcated
market with commodity growers,
and then craft growers,
really hyper focused on
quality and incorporating more
technology and more precision.
In the marketplace
side, I'm not sure
if it's what I
believe will happen
or what I just hope will happen.
AUDIENCE: I'll
take it either way.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: One of
the things that has been,
frankly, a little frustrating
for specialty coffee people,
James has talked about this idea
of coffee is culinary for us
as a core belief.
But when I meet
people who don't know
what Intelligentsia is, well
my first thing is say, what?
You don't know what
Intelligentsia is?
But I try to explain it to
people, like family members who
don't know what I
do, I say, well, it's
like a farm to table
restaurant for coffee.
And I think so much of
what's exciting about--
and has been exciting
about our food culture
over the last 10 or
20 years, the idea
that James mentioned
of seasonality,
of relentless search for
flavor, local ingredients,
fresh ingredients.
All of those things that make
our food culture so exciting
are really fundamental to
the way we source coffee
and the way we try to position
coffee in the marketplace.
And I feel like there has
been-- coffee hasn't--
we see ourselves very much
as part of that movement.
And in some senses, the work
that we've done in our sourcing
predates a lot of the work
that's been done in food.
But we haven't been
mapped into that.
And so we talk a lot
about wine in coffee,
and I think it's
probably a case of envy,
where we want to
be more like wine.
But we think it's
instructive and it's
important in a lot of ways.
Chemically, coffee is
more complex than wine.
It has the same kind of things
that you think about wine.
A vintage, well every
year, Finca Takesi
produces a Geisha
varietal that's
somewhat different
from the previous year.
And it depends on
all the things that
affect the vintages of wine.
So there's a lot of really
good analogies there.
And I think coffee--
to James's point about
coffee's complexity
being under-appreciated,
we feel like coffee's time
is coming in terms
of being really
appreciated as the culinary
product that it is.
And as James said, we're
also searching for our role,
and trying to help people
appreciate that, and help
move specialty to that moment.
I hope that's in our future.
JOHN PETRENKO: Yeah, definitely
AUDIENCE: So with
the wine analogy,
I was kind of thinking about
when coffee has its "Sideways"
moment, you know, how
that movie came out.
But no, my question
is more about--
the thing I've sort
of noticed and have
commented when I-- so
I live in Lake View,
and I go to Lake View Cafe.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I noticed
[INAUDIBLE] I love it.
And I feel a lot more like
it's an experiential thing when
I go there.
Like it feels much more
curated, not just the selection,
but also--
I feel myself approaching
it a little differently.
And I have a spouse
who steadfastly
refuses to drink coffee.
He won't touch it.
It frustrates the hell out
of me because I'm like,
there's so many things
you're missing, right?
And then I also have
friends who are like,
I go to Dunkin' Donuts
and get a buzz on.
And so, how does that spectrum--
how do I make my friends
into coffee snobs?
No, how do you view
the experiential bent
that Intelligentsia
occupies as sort
of that niche in the market?
And how do you
expand that if you're
talking about complexity
when a lot of people
don't necessarily notice it?
Is there like a
"Sideways" moment that you
think the industry needs?
Are you driving that?
Is the supplier driving that?
Are small neighborhood
places going to drive that?
How do you see that happening?
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
I think to answer at least
part of your question,
we have this belief
that coffee should be
treated as a culinary product.
And so if we emulated the
traditional fast food model,
I don't think we could have
gotten to where we have today.
And so part of it is, we have
to do something different
for customers to
come in and say,
yeah, I'm OK paying $6
for a black cup of coffee
even though I can go down
the street to Dunkin' Donuts
and get it for $2.
So having an experience,
a complete experience
for customers I think is really
important for us as a brand.
We don't have an
interest in having
5,000 Intelligentsias
around Chicago,
or around the United States.
We want to keep
this pretty boutique
and grow the brand through
the coffee bar experience,
but then it's available in
a lot of different places,
at your Whole Foods, at your
office, wherever it may be.
But one thing that
we struggle with
is, not everyone wants to wait
six minutes for a pour over.
And particularly at our downtown
locations, it's something
that we talk about
a lot, how do we
meet customers where they
want a great cup of coffee,
they're not willing
to wait six minutes?
And it's something that,
candidly, we struggle with.
Because we don't want it
to become fast foodie,
right, like too much like a fast
food experience, because then
we lose the credibility
around, hey,
this is a culinary experience.
But at the same time,
if there's customers
that want to come in and
get a great cup of coffee
but get it quickly, we
want to serve them too.
And I think one of
the things that we--
one of the cool parts of
getting to design a coffee
bar every time we open one,
it's both maddening and cool
because it's like, OK, we've
got to start from scratch again,
we don't have this
cookie cutter template.
But we do get to experiment
with service models.
And so I'll give you an example.
Like our Logan Square
shop here in Chicago,
a barista comes over,
you sit at the bar,
the barista will wait
on you, you can engage.
The baristas will kind
of read the customer
and try to figure out
how much they want
to engage about the coffee.
Like, do they want to
talk about the coffee
or are they just here for--
you know, they just want the cup
of coffee and leave me alone,
I just woke up.
So there's that experience.
But then you can also
at the front of the bar,
you can get a coffee to go.
And it should be a
faster experience.
And so I can't say that
we've cracked that nut,
but it's definitely
something that we're still
trying to figure out.
Because I want to--
I mean, one of the
things we all want to do
is introduce more people,
your wife, your friends
to this cup of coffee.
Because I think once you
try it, you're hooked,
and it's hard to go back
to the Dunkin' Donuts.
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: I think also,
it should be said that we--
our obsession with quality, we
have a lighter roast profile
than most.
And that really is
not by accident.
I mean, it's a reflection
of the quality of the coffee
that we source.
One of my colleagues
recently put it so well,
I think, for a
non-coffee person.
He was saying that, if you get
a beautiful piece of tuna that's
sushi grade, you don't
even have to cook it,
you can just eat it.
But if you get an old piece of
tuna that's not the best cut,
you got to cook it for a long
time to make it palatable.
And it's sort of like
that with coffee.
We're sourcing some of
the world's finest coffee.
You don't need to layer on all
of that caramelization and all
that bitterness that you
get in the deep, dark roast.
You can create something
really beautiful by letting
your foot off the gas and
letting it breathe at a lighter
roast profile.
So we tend to regard the
really dark carbonized coffee
as not culinary.
You know, you're not
tasting the terroir,
you're not tasting the
work, you're tasting
the hand of the roaster.
And so, you know,
most of us who are
coffee professionals
in Intelligentsia,
we don't reach for
the dark roast.
But even our dark roast, we
try to reimagine the dark roast
for a kind of a
specialty audience.
So our dark roast, if you
put it next to a brand who
shall not be mentioned, they're
occupying different planets.
And so I think to your point,
meeting people where they are,
and this idea of a
journey, and trying
to help people
discover coffee, we
want to have a dark roast
that's, hey, try this,
reimagine your dark roast.
It doesn't have to
taste like an ashtray.
There's some nuance there,
there's some citrus,
there's some sweetness,
but you're still
getting that slight little
bite, and something that you go,
oh, this is a different
kind of thing.
And I think it should be said
as I look at three different tap
systems in the back of the room,
part of the future of coffee
is coffee as an ingredient,
and coffee as an ingredient
in the broader beverage market.
And so I think we can
look down our nose at some
of those things,
or we can say, hey,
this is an opportunity to
engage people and meet them
where they are and where
they're having coffee
with a product that's superior.
And try to bring
them into a deeper
appreciation for everything
that companies like ours do.
JOHN PETRENKO: Very cool.
SAM SABORI: Yeah, I think
that that "Sideways"
moment is going to come
when everybody understands
seasonality.
And it's going to be, I'm not
drinking any past crop coffee.
So I think if anything, anything
that we can really, really push
is that seasonality
to say, if you're
going to any cafe and
you order what's fresh,
we found the freshest coffees
tend to perform better,
whether or not the roast is
as ideal, or a little bit off.
So there's that.
And I think that's kind of
touching on the fourth wave
also, is when the
customer understands
what we're trying to do.
I think that's where a
fourth wave-- when we're
meeting the customer
and they're coming
to us willing to pay $10, $15.
Because I think that's
already out there,
it's just very small--
AUDIENCE: Right.
SAM SABORI: Very
small companies.
AUDIENCE: Like a tasting menu?
SAM SABORI: Yeah, exactly.
JAMES MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah, exactly.
JOHN PETRENKO: All right.
Well, I believe
we're out of time.
I would like to thank--
MICHAEL SHERIDAN: Thanks.
JOHN PETRENKO: --James,
Sam, and Michael again,
and the whole Intelligentsia
team for coming out to Google.
This has been great.
Come feel free to
bother us after this.
And I believe there
will be coffee cocktails
and some coffee
demos coming up soon.
So let's give around of
applause for our guests.
[APPLAUSE]